here's what a map all is so I'll use my
hands to talk here so if you think about
a cube and I put my two matrices that
I'm multiplying on two faces of the cube
right you can think about the Matrix
multiply as okay the N cubed I'm going
to multiply for each one in the cubed
and then I'm going to do a sum which is
a reduce up to here to the third face of
the cube and that's your multiplied
Matrix
so what a matrix multiply is is a bunch
of shape operations right a bunch of
permute reshapes and expands on the two
matrices
I'll multiply n cubed a reduce n cubed
which gives you an N squared Matrix
okay so what what is the minimum number
of operations that can accomplish that
if you don't have that mall as a
primitive so tiny grad has about 20. um
and you can compare tiny grad's uh opsat
or IR to things like xla or Prim torch
so xlan printorch are ideas we're like
okay torch has like 2 000 different
kernels
um pytorch 2.0 introduced Prim torch
which has only 250.
tiny grad has order of magnitude 25.
it's it's 10x less than xli or print
torch and you can think about it as kind
of like Risk versus Sisk right these
other things are cisc like systems uh
tendergrad is risk
and risk one
risk architecture is going to change
everything 1995 hackers
wait really that's an actual thing
Angelina Jolie delivers the line risk
architecture is going to change
everything in 1995. and here we are with
arm and the phones
an arm everywhere wow I love it when
movies actually have real things in them
right